the joggin experience I mean I've heard
intelligent people make this
conversation about other intelligent
people that disagree with them like ben
shapiro that like ben shapiro should be
deep platformed because Ben Shapiro is
indoctrinating people towards right-wing
ideology by having these salient points
and articulate sentences and these these
rants that he goes on or he speaks very
fast he's got a great grasp with the
English language and it's very
compelling yeah and the idea is that
he's indoctrinating young people well no
he's speaking with passion well I don't
agree with him on a lot of things yeah
but I certainly agree with his right to
express himself and he's not convincing
me
who is he convincing like when he's
talks when ben shapiro here's a here's
an area where we deeply disagree gay
people
he thinks it's immoral he thinks he
would never go to a gay person's wedding
he wouldn't have he wouldn't even go to
the celebration the after party of a gay
wedding and I'm like well this is all
for religious reasons I'm like that
there's I think that's ridiculous that's
not convincing me so who is it
convincing is it convincing someone
that's a baby are you dealing with
children are we dealing with uneducated
people are we dealing with people that
don't have positive influences what's
wrong with letting him express these
ideas these ideas are hot I mean he and
I had like a long conversation about it
on the podcast well I was like I think
it's ridiculous like what do you care my
perspective is what do you care and his
perspective is he couldn't support that
because of religious reasons so then we
go deep into the hole with why but what
are these religious reasons like how
deep do you go with this do you think
Jesus came back from the dead like he
doesn't he's Jewish it's a different
perspective but do you think you know
this do you really think that God thinks
that homosexuality is some sort of a
carnal sin and and and terrible if so
God made everything why did he make
homosexuals please explain that what
what kind of a weirdo is God that he
gives people this urge to be gay but
then he tells them fight that urge
and then he makes this comparison -
that's like murder sometimes you want to
murder people my okay I think that's
different because you don't want to
murder people all day every day I know a
lot of gay dudes who want to [ __ ] dudes
all the time it's like it's God did a
crazy thing to their system and for you
to believe in God but have a problem
with that to me is ridiculous so now
we're banking on these really ancient
words that were written by people with
no grasp of science no understanding of
biology no understanding of the culture
of the world no understanding of the the
sheer number of these people and taking
into perspective that you know you're
literally dealing with I don't know what
percentage of the population is gay but
it's a significant percentage so you're
saying all of them are frying in hell do
you know dumb that is that's really
[ __ ] dumb like if they're your
neighbors and they're just happy and
loving what do you care the goal should
be a cohesive society where people are
comfortably being around each other with
all their differences just nice people
just nice to each other exactly it
doesn't matter if you're gay or straight
or trans or black or white or Asian or
[ __ ] whatever it doesn't it shouldn't
matter the individual should matter and
the way we interact with each other that
should matter and we have to take any
consideration that if you're going to
live your life by these things that were
written down thousands of years ago
before people had any of these
understandings of all the subtle nuances
of humanity and all the differences that
people have and and and now the
biological understands why they have
these differences well you're dealing
with ignorance you think you're you're
applying these ancient ignorant rules to
a modern world well we have a vastly
expanded understanding of human beings
right but to Ben's credit I mean he's
friends with Dave he doesn't love ya but
he says he's gonna cut him off - my
weddings like I can't you're a sinner
but [ __ ] off but you know what a lot of
us who have parents who are super
Christian yeah like I understand my at
the end of the day you know where that's
coming from she my sister is gay and and
ever she didn't she didn't accept that
and and the reason for that it was that
it was coming from a good place like for
her it was I don't want my daughter to
go to hell
it's like it's like it's again the road
to hell is paved with good intentions
right and so so the only reason she was
objecting to it was because of this
belief that she's gonna end up burning
in hell so it's coming from an
ironically a place of love right um it's
judgy yes and it's based on Bronze Age
ideology yeah but but you know I I don't
think that that either of us ever
doubted that she loved her right and
it's so I kinda understand where Ben
comes from in that sense even though I I
you know it makes me angry like I you
know reject all that stuff it's just
silly and what's interesting is he's so
smart and when he talks about that it's
all the sudden you see stammering and he
gets weird because he knows it's
nonsense but I don't know if he knows I
don't know he's just deep he's just
balls deep in his religion let's just
say I like the guy a lot I really do and
I've gotten so much [ __ ] for saying that
I like the guy you know you make more of
that we need more of the I hate the you
know hate the signal the center and
practice on both sides but I think he
and I only have we disagree on some
issues and some political issues but
he's a decent person he's a nice person
he's very friendly he's funny I enjoy
his company a lot I like ben shapiro
i really do i think he's a brilliant guy
right i mean the gay things the biggest
one cuz me that's the dumbest one like
my my it always comes back to why do you
care that's all it is to me like why do
you care i don't care like why you care
someone's gay like if it if it does it
affect you how can it how can it affect
you right you do you have your fingers
and everybody's business like it's crazy
yeah doesn't make any sense to me I mean
no it's that argument against gay
marriage like what why does it affect
your heterosexual marriage exactly it
shouldn't well the sanctity of marriage
it's so dumb the sanctity of marriage
how about Vegas you could go to a
[ __ ] drive-thru you can get you get
married drive-thru movie theater I mean
that's really what it's like get married
anywhere that's so dumb
so so ridiculous
[Applause]